hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to sorry
about all this it's just I'm really
concerned because I heard you know who
might be in town saij yes
you're looking good you can work it out
in something new haircut new wardrobe
penis enhancement silence so what do you
want with me mentally demented one my
day of reckoning critic my day that has
been coming for nearly four years
reckoning that little cameo of mine in
your Care Bears reveal could only save
me for so long critical a bowling proper
crossover well I guess that's fine with
me
I'll just get over the next five years
now critic well no offense age but
anything having to do with you scares
the shit out of me I mean you don't
review things that are well you are not
well it took me a while critic but I
finally found the perfect movie for us
to review oh no I see what you review
you're not gonna make me review cops
with grenades tied to their pubes or
something Riddick
have a little more faith in me than that
what if I show you something
personal collection it probably kill you
if you die then I'd have no one to play
with so I bring you start chaser the
legend of Oran you kidding doesn't look
that bad
you're not afraid but you've got some
Edie's cheese some bland story and
actually some half-decent animation well
it's kind of stupid and silly but this
doesn't look awful
no I'm not afraid you will be so it
seems I've been shanghaied into
reviewing another fossilized piece of
shit that nobody saw the first time it
came out apparently Starchaser was
released in 1985 and flopped harder than
a fat guy in America's Funniest Home
Videos
oh come on critic you've got to give
them credit for making the best 3d movie
ever made or at least that's what they
see on the poster
oh sure because as we all know 3d is the
gatekeeper to good quality entertainment
but Kate Winslet's nipple in 3d does
have potential so to be fair the movie
starts out all right I mean the
animation looks like heavy metal threw
up on a Molly Hatchet album cover but
it's harmless well as harmless as forced
labor in a dangerous mind can be this is
our hero Orin who despite having lived
his entire life in this subterranean
world as a slave still manages to have a
head of finely shampooed luxuriant hair
don't you won't survive doing the work
of tools
prettiest girl in the world I do the
work of 10 yeah have you seen Jeff's got
that chick that's smokin oh but you're
hot you're hot do you have a nice tooth
it seems that Oren and his friends are
slave laborers that mine crystals for a
god named Saigon no not that Saigon not
as I got either this Saigon just your
continued subjugation and your free will
really you're taking advantage of us so
after the slaves offer their mind
crystals in exchange for food or in
habits upon a strange sword embedded in
the rock wall
that's why we'll go to the Dagobah from
Yoda oh I'm sure that's just a
coincidence
yeah so not OB one says that there are
other worlds outside of the caverns and
that the wielder of the sword can free
all the slaves if he is able to find the
blade selector pointlessly wrestling
with another slave Orin takes what's
left of the sword and vows to find the
blade will go together alone Oh were you
with us in spirit Kelly
it's too dangerous for one as young as
you because I can't no we don't want you
because your ball crating ly annoying
it's like he talks in that tone of voice
whenever you're trying to mimic someone
just sound really whiny child stop
robbing well Lauren and his girlfriend
ditched the little turd and make up fur
I don't know where exactly I guess they
just figured that the way out of the
caves that their people have lived in
for generations has to be somewhere but
they don't get too far
all right so they give the slaves
dangerous laser drills that could take
out a guard in one hit and give the
guards whips this isn't an S&M bar why
don't you give them some guns point
taken
Oren and his girlfriend get captured
trying to escape where they learned that
the God who they've been worshipping all
their lives turns out to be God some guy
yet really was this supposed to be in
any way surprising Christ which is
starting this movie and the dramatic
reveal is already wasted this isn't much
of a twist anyway it's not really that
big an impact if you don't get to know
the characters we barely even grown
accustomed to Oren or do what's-her-face
but I guess it doesn't matter it's not
like she's gonna die in the next five
minutes try one
well she was completely pointless wasn't
she you don't even know the half of it
this world above I'm fine to feel along
or in manages to escape Zygons clutches
into a collapsed cavern he digs his way
out onto the surface world but it's not
long before he runs into more danger
sage
what's dad alibi no it looks like he
crawled out of the asshole of a char
Giger's nightmare no this looks like he
crawled out of the asshole of HR Giger's
nightmare
so my new nightmares for the week take
oran prisoner and decided who gets what
body part of Oren's ooh I'll take the
brain oh wait no that won't fill me up
enough but one of the ungodly
monstrosities gets a little too curious
with Oren's sword and winds up cleaving
one of the others in half or and manages
to trick the last of the remaining
monsters into letting him go in yeah big
deal tricking things that couldn't
figure their way out of a Chinese finger
trap exactly 10 seconds to tell me what
you're doing in this swamp oh hi I'm
solo what are you talking about oh wait
a minute
a young kid on a distant backwater world
finds a magic sword under the
instruction of a wise old man finds a
rogue smuggler to help him defeat a dark
overlord yeah he's a smuggler Star Wars
yeah you're pretty much right star
chaser even goes beyond lifting plot
elements and characters and rips off
iconic shots from the original trilogy I
can't believe it this is shameful this
is insulting this is downright
unforgivable oh you want to know what
the best part is what the same people
who distributed this in theaters also
distributed the Garbage Pail Kids movie
but I got crusty elbows wasn't that hell
are you doing that's our hero ladies and
gentlemen guy who trips over himself
when slightly tapped from behind this Oh
God feels disgusting with Ewing anything
by those babe like this Han Solo wannabe
is named a who tells Orin that the
crystals he's been mining for all his
life our comely thought to be mined by
robots but the scene is interrupted by a
swamp monster that grabs dag
no how come the sword works now but not
when he tried to stab dag
well critic the movie never really
explains why the sword works sometimes
and not other times and several fan
theories have floated around to this day
wait wait wait this movie has fans yeah
in fact just recently it's been
announced that plans are being made for
a live-action remake they did that it
was called Star Wars oh and if this
movie hasn't pushed all your rage
buttons by now it also has its own
version of Navi from Legend of Zelda all
fancy fucking that I'd like to think so
well we don't linger on the possible
molestation for long as the patrol comes
along and starts attacking the two and
they retreat back to dag ship I wish
you'd stop calling me your computer dag
it's so impersonal after all your body's
just a machine made of flesh and blood
how would you like it if I went around
calling your refrain oh hi c-3po oh wait
a minute
not even a robot okay so what do you
call an AI that speaks in a prissy whiny
and feminine voice and is largely used
for comic relief another bitch it is
c-3po oh I told you it wouldn't work
by the way does dake ever finish that
cigar do people just not know how to
smoke things in space Roger that's
unlikely cuz they came up with a
straight way didn't they
okay so the to fly off would Dagg
deciding to attack a nearby base because
well the movie has to find a way to
shoehorn more lifted shots from Star
Wars that way also eighty eighties much
dad manages to steal some of the mind
crystals from a nearby transport ship
but Saigon captures dad before they can
make off but of course Oran not being
the sharpest tool in the shed demands
that the ship be lowered so he could
confront Saigon head-on you know my
sword
you know is hopelessly dumb and naive or
it is at least he's incredibly weak an
awkward lets pointlessly carry this
heavy robot that is in no way going to
help us escape and will in fact only
hinder our chances of making it safely
aboard
God I'm a tactical genius but of course
this movie isn't said in any kind of
logical universe so many in fact make it
safely aboard and blast off leaving
Saigon to mutter one of the strangest
lines in the movie it is him ha that's
return what is returned as return the
cars returned this will be full of cock
I never realize it left
well critic if you thought that was
strange get a load of dag Tring to
reconfigure that FEM body picked up from
earlier where the hell are the
personality circuits on these jutsu
fembot their inner austere Ian
you wouldn't dare
he's not seriously going to oh he's
going there see that look on his face
that's the look of a man is about to
plunder him some ass what sorry folks
had a flashback there for a moment it
just gets better and better
give them a few more seconds we'll have
a cinema snob review dag why do you risk
your life stealing crystals and how the
hell did this movie only get a PG rating
wait that should do it
well that seals it you went from star
wars to star wars in a matter of seconds
well if there's one thing we can all
learn who the star tracer is that the
way to a woman's heart whereas where the
hell did this thing come from what
thought it was a bright idea to have de
proba Fembots but a fembot if you will
do me one think of the fact that there's
a children's audience that will most
likely see this probably because they're
the only ones that would find this
remotely funny
no wonder they ripped off Star Wars the
original ideas and this are just won't
ever find the more wretched hive of scum
and to the may so after the to blast off
into a Jackson Pollock painting or an in
dad part ways with dag meeting up with
the film's version of Jabba the Hutt to
hawk the crystals he stole Oh dag one of
my nosy men thought they saw you with a
young boy this evening my girl still not
excite you anymore you know that is
exactly what this family-friendly space
adventure needed better philia jokes
well dad and robot ass play mean well or
it happens upon a fortune teller who
gives him advice and where to find the
missing played to his sword can you tell
me where I'll find a blade such is not
an easy task
hey genius you've been using the sword
all throughout the movie the blades
feasible you've already found it you
might as well be trying to find the
biggest douche in the universe case
closed
Dagon or and meet Becca but it's not
long before Zygons men are after them
again
prompting dag and the FEM ba to enact
the oldest and dumbest trick in the book
the sexy lady diversion of course this
fold is dirt tactic is so stupid that it
works perfectly seriously the only way
this could have been worse is if you
fell for the carrot under the Box trap
that second guy get knocked out nothing
touches him see thang hits one of them
with the butt of his gun and the other
guy just falls over like he's wounded
you'll be stone dead in a moment
luckily Dagon or and managed to elude
Zygons none and they escaped so we bent
to another planet I think could be the
same planner with the mine world or the
same planet as that desert town
establishing shot what's that
but in any cases I guns men managed to
catch up add egg in Oran and shoot their
ship down the Zygons man take DAGs
unconscious body in but are unable to
find Oran who has been flown from the
ship during the crash and landed torso
first in a tree
oh good does this mean he suffered
catastrophic injury and died roll the
credits
oh hi Bubba Fett oh hi Princess Leia
yeah you knew she was coming maybe not
technically a princess but daughter of
some sort of rich person in yeah
princess
so Princess Leia takes or in a way to
her castle because the moon suit and
orang wakes up in her bedroom wearing
the most embarrassing blue midriff vest
our undershirts extinct in this universe
how come an 80 sci-fi men always while
we're even less than the women do you on
my name is avianna
who was alone a friend from the mines
yeah just a friend and totally not my
love interests who died just a few days
ago seriously is this movie gonna force
this romantic relationship on us it's
bad enough that the girl in the caves
was killed in the first 20 minutes but
now she's just cast aside for another I
said you had no idea how useless that
character was didn't I Oren and Leia
decide that this thing for them to do is
head back to orange cavern planet who
was your father why more bro of course
Supreme Governor of the board Agong
system I'm getting sick and tired of
never understanding but Oren never
understanding is what your best dad
meanwhile dag is being held prisoner by
Zygon and I think you know where this is
going try to imagine a needle the
thickness of a human hair
slowly thrust between your eyes
so it's been discovered that orange
blade has been passed down from person
to person destroying the rule of tyrants
for hundreds of years or annan Leia
decide that but this thing for them to
do is head back to Orange cavern planet
I'm sorry this is a restricted area
wait did you say shoot me that doesn't
sound pleasant maybe I should do
something like an actual guard robot god
I'm a poor model watch I'm doing let me
try no that's a coincidence but of
course breaking into Zygons lair
haphazardly as its disadvantages like
being immediately captured not just a
robot I have been putting the pieces
back together
he's more machine than man
so Oren is thrown into jail next to dag
with the blade and Zygons possession
nothing could stop him from taking over
and enslaving the humans in fact this
blade is so important that Saigon's just
leaves it out in the open on a console
board how much you want to bet that's
gonna bite him in the ass
conqueror of man folks got dances don't
be so of course the twinkling
dingleberry sneaks the hild out of the
regions I GaN and Orrin uses it to
escape guard I have something for you oh
boy oh boy I hope it is candy that is
not candy so Orrin a dag managed to
sneak aboard one of Zygons ships as they
leave to destroy humanity space fleet
yes yeah we're supposed to care about
some fleet you've never even seen in
this movie oh and I mean literally never
seen we never see a single space ship of
theirs or even the planet which they're
protecting my god I'm so invested
luckily the fembot managed to fix the
ship and rejoin Zoran and dag as they
managed to overtake control of the
flagship leading the attack and with a
simple push of a button detonates all
the missiles in the entire fleet
effectively destroying every ship Christ
of a single button push could do that
I'd hate to see what would happen if a
guy accidentally spilled his coffee in
the control boards Orrin and the gang
managed to break back into Saigon space
for what the third time now but Saigon
manages to ensnare orange ship in a
tractor beam leaving the Fen bond and
dag ship to make the save and take their
place in the beam I'm not sure that's
how the tractor beams work but if the
filmmakers don't care then why the fuck
should I flash it dissipates all of the
basis defences leaving Orin to face
Saigon one on one but it looks like leia
decides to go after or in any ways after
seeing Saigon pursue after him and gets
her ass captured as the two were
fighting like a complete dumbass
oh she will die
okay you tried to use the sword before
and it has never worked for you why the
fuck do you think will work for you now
it seems all hope is lost but Navi shows
up again and tells Orin that he never
needed the sword in the first place why
the fuck did he just tell him this way
back at the beginning the same reason
the Good Witch didn't tell Dorothy about
the shoes sending her back home
some people are dicks with his newfound
power or include Sue's igon and leads
his people to revolt against the slave
masters but with the entire mind world
collapsing from the explosions above
Orin thinks fast and bullshitty by get
this throwing the sword at the ceiling
which magically clears the way for the
rest of the people to safely evacuate
and if that wasn't enough or it even
cures the little bastard from before of
his blindness because why the fuck not I
can finally see that you're not wearing
a shirt on that guy that creeps me out
we finally end this turn with space
Jesus here being offered by the old guy
from way at the beginning to join him in
being glowy and shit like he turns him
down in favor of getting some tape not
yet
I'd like to stretch my legs for your
decade the choice is yours
thank God it's over let me tell you this
was a dumb dumb movie I mean beyond all
the plot points characters and shots
that they stole from Star Wars it's just
a lazy well admit the animation can be
good at some times but the whole story
is just a complete mess of half-baked
ideas and sloppy execution and it's just
frustratingly blatant how much they're
ripping off Star Wars I'm sorry it
really gets in the way but I did it I
stood up to your movie and I got through
it what do you think that Apple's bitch
I'll admit you fared better than I
expected
can't wait to see how you'll respond
with my stuff
cool
you
cuca has returned